[Applause]
um
you spoke about how you meeting nipsey
changed your life
yeah kind of obviously you know nipsey's
one of the greats rest in peace man he
was a
close friend of mine um still can't
believe man
it's about to be two years next year in
march um
what what was your interaction with
nipsey and how did that affect you
because isn't that crazy energy
you don't think that's crazy the fact
that like i'm the i'm becoming one of
the
pop artists like one of the big pop
artists like i'm becoming like
i'm becoming like phil collins like the
new york times had phil collins it's a
whole nother type of pop we're talking
too
yes yeah like like timeless iconic
pop right and um
i'm becoming that
and uh so say okay so say this
right say gashi becomes the new like
george michael phil collins sting of
this generation where i'm like
timeless and everyone's like coming to
my shows i sold out
like i'm like i'm doing the garden yeah
just saying bringing garth brooks out
yeah like twice like doing like right
right sell that garden
twice right becoming legendary kids are
losing their mind
and becoming like [ __ ] insane right
to say there's videos of me and nipsey
in the studio after that
how insane is that story you know i
think it's a it's a you know your come
up man
it's it's insane coming up as a rapper
out of new york
it's insane yeah it's crazy you know i
met this guy
through uh shout out to my friend austin
rosen he made it possible he brought
nipsey to the studio and
austin uh austin manages post malone
like he's like he's the reason for
postman being as big as he is
uh austin rosen um brought nipsey to his
studio brought me in
played the record and if she loved it
told me i was dope enough to to really
make it happen and after i met nipsey
nipsey i felt it was real and i could
drop out make it happen he made me feel
that way
so you met so nipsy was coming in to lay
a verse for you or just to work
so nipsy came into the studio with uh
this guy named johnny
and um shipes yeah austin was like
well i want to get nipsey on this record
i want to play him the record so we
played in record he's like oh this is
tight this was your record this is my
record yeah and then
we got nipsey's like this just fire we
just jumped in a booth cut it real quick
and then he's telling me you know me
like i was telling him like i really
want to do this [ __ ] and he was like oh
yes
it should fire bro like you can do it
and like
like nipsey was my favorite upcoming
rapper yeah
so i was telling austin about him i was
like i'll get him on a verse like it's
nothing because he was
just coming up so you could get nipsey
universe you know and um
because i looked at i was looking at
nipsey like our generation snoop
yeah you know i think when he first came
out that was kind of like
they look very similar they look similar
they're both very similar
not similar but they had very each of
them had a very distinct tone
yeah and they look like the you know
they look like he's a [ __ ] and right
he was just so hard like paul skinny
skinny with the with the plaids and the
jeans at the converse like it was just
so snoop
and i was like yo this guy is going to
be our snoop our icon
and i was like he's going to be the
biggest
and everybody around me is like what the
hell are you talking about dog i was
like
yo can i get him on a verse it's like i
can make that call that's nothing
you know what i mean everyone around is
like it's not a big deal but
i think i think you know what like not
to toot my own horn man but
i think i have the vision to see
somebody in 20 years
to see somebody in 10 years to see
somebody i could look at somebody and
know if they're going to be somebody or
not in the music business
yeah man nipsey was one of those guys uh
the first time i met him was an 09 he
came in freestyle on my show in boise
idaho when i was doing radio and boise
wow that was my first full-time job
crazy and uh killed it probably
yeah he had a mixtape out called bullets
ain't got no name oh i love that i love
still
i still play it yeah part one and two
right two is my [ __ ] roll the windows up
oh my god but yeah rest in peace to
nipsy